字幕: Shohei Okumura
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
（拍手）
皆さん はじめまして
素数ゼミをずっと研究していた
わけではないんですけど
虫が大好きで
もうハイハイする頃から
毛虫を採ってとかやってたんですけど
それで気が付いたら
小学校５年の頃には生物学者になる
もう決めたわけですね
小学校の成績は平均３です
１年２年のときは平均２以下です
だからもう超低脳児だったんですね
ところが それでも生物科学者になると
決めたら諦めないことですね
で それで
それも理学部に行く
なぜ役に立たない生物学
虫を見て暮らしたい
一生遊んで暮らそう
それだけです
それで行きました
一生遊べました
遊んだ成果です
じゃあ
まず 次に行きましょうか
素数ゼミというのは
これ交尾しているの珍しいでしょ
滅多に見れないセミの交尾って
で これアメリカの素数ゼミ
学名は僕ら科学者は
周期ゼミというんですけど
なんとウィキペディアで
最初に掲載されたのは
素数ゼミなんです
なぜか
僕が名前で呼んだから
そっちが優先されたんですね
まぁいいとして
13年が南側 17年が北側で
モザイクになっている地域が
両方ある地域
でも一周期しか存在しないんですね
マサチューセッツのケープコッド
に行った時に
ある年 わーっと鳴くわけですね
そしたら17年後にしか鳴かないんです
そういう変わったセミです
もうダーウィンの頃から
疑問視されてて
どうしてだろう どうしてだろうって
みんな数学者とか科学者が頑張って
生物学者解いたんですけど
解けなかった
理由は
生物を知らない
セミって有名じゃないんです　アメリカでは
17年バッタとか呼んでるんです
イナゴとか
だから セミなんて知らないわけですよ
だから もちろん祖先が何かって
考えないんです
でも祖先がいなかったら
人間いないです
同じです
祖先から考えなくちゃいけない
日本は
いっぱいセミがいます
アブラゼミとか
７年くらいかかるというんですけど
実際アロエで育てると２年半です
３年かからないです
だから決まっていないんです
年数が
そういうのが 何でこんなに進化した
もちろん
次 見ましょう
氷河期です
氷河期で７年だったものが
14年15年16年どんどん伸びてくわけで
要するに餌は水ですから
導管を通っている
木の水ですから
ほとんど栄養ないですから
でも吸い上げる量というのは
温度に依存しちゃうんです
冬の間寝てるんです
だから結局10何年もかかってた
それで絶滅を避けなくちゃいけない
だから氷河期の絶滅を避けてる過程で
最終的に素数が生き残っている
絶滅を避けてたら周期があるわけです
獲得した
その周期同士のぶつかり合いの時に
一番素数がぶつかんなくて
安泰だ それだけです
それが何を意味するか
生物の進化です
生物の進化っていうのは全て
絶滅を避けていく
そこが始点なんですね
教科書面白いですね
平均適応度というんですね
小学校２年の考え方ですよね
掛け算 ねずみ算３つ掛けたら８です
ところが ２掛ける１掛ける３は６匹
劣っているんです
でも生物学の教科書と
同じだというんです
ところが２掛ける７掛ける０は
０匹です
最終的に
３世代目には絶滅してます
ところが ３匹 平均３匹だから
これが一番いいというんです
それが生物学の教科書なんです
今でもそうです
間違っています
だから いかに教科書を鵜呑みにしたら
何もできない
ちゃんと自分で一から
考えればいいんです
僕が91年にコリンクラークと
一緒に書いて
平均適応度以外にも考え方が
ありますって書いた
だからこれが10年20年したら
教科書になるわけです
で まだまだ全然変わってないですね
だから何が一番いけないか
０が一番いけない
絶滅を避ける
生物は進化の過程で
それを学んできたんです
ところが  もちろん絶滅しちゃう
生物もいっぱいいます
恐竜とかいろいろな生物絶滅してます
理由があります
まぁ
そういう生物の考え方というのは
最適なもの そのとき支配的なものが
生き残るのではなく
最適じゃないけど生き残れるように
ちょっと引いてるものが
ずっと残っていくわけです
１番最悪な時に
絶滅を避けて抜けていく連中
おんなじ事が
環境変化にどう適応するのが
１番重要になる
モンシロチョウでもあります
モンシロチョウの場合は
キャベツは人間が作っている
殺虫剤もまく
だから人間が大敵なんですね
面白いのはコーネル大学の先生たちが
ルートとカレイバらで
農学部の害虫学の先生たちが
論文書いたんですね
モンシロチョウの
リスクスプレッディングですよ
強大な巨大なアメリカのキャベツ畑で
卵１卵産んだら
どっか飛んでいっちゃう
当たり前ですよね
キャベツ畑に全部産んだら
殺虫剤で全部死んじゃいます
だから野草に産まなくちゃいけないんです
野草は成長率が悪くて
イヌガラシはこんなにちっちゃいんですね
成虫まで育たないんです
だから大変なんです それでも殺虫剤
かかんないんです 収穫されない
だから生き残ります
それが絶滅回避なんです
同じことは他にもあります
90年代にDNA
フィンガープリンティング
びっくりしました
鳥類学者とかバードウォッチャー
生態学者でも鳥の好きな生態学者
みんな目を皿のようにして
観察してんです
ところが誰もわからなかったんです
５匹に１匹 卵を見たら
子ども ひなを見たら
ひなの羽毛でDNA鑑定できるんです
何と５匹に１匹 ４匹に１匹くらいが
父親が違うんです
なんと浮気の子なんです
びっくりです
色々な種で調べました
ほとんどの種が
平均が４匹から５匹に１匹なんです
ひどいと75パーセントって
だからほとんど浮気の子です
自分の子がいるのかなってなっちゃいます
怖いですね
色々そういう問題はあるんです
でもメスにとっては必然なんですね
２割くらいのペアのオスが
不妊因子を持っていたりするんです
そうするとじゃあ貞淑を守って
絶対そのお父さんだけにしか
お父さんの子しか作らないよってやっていたら
そういう
５匹に１匹くらいのメスは
絶滅しちゃうわけです
こうやって
不妊を避けるために浮気してる
連中だけが生き残るんです
だからそういう風な結果になってる
絶滅を避けるってことが
重要なんです
自分から見て絶滅を避ける
自分の子どもたちが絶滅を避ける
それが最も重要なんです
オスの環境は
お父さんは環境なんです
お母さんと
だからそれを変化で
たまには変化する
偶然
ばつを引く
その時に適応させて
長期的には存続できる
そういうことなんです
生物進化も人間活動も同じです
人間の動物行動も同じなんですけど
人間経済活動いきましょうね
その方が面白いから
次の 企業 日本企業は面白いですね
日本企業は
非常に儲かったとか言って
みんなに配らないですよね
10倍に利益が上がったら
給料10倍になりますか
なんないです
社長がいっぱいとりますか
１億円取りますか
なんないです
あがんないんです
蓄えになるんです
会社の
そして
なんか 経済が ロシア戦争が
なんとかだって
気象変動だって
なんかあった時も
じゃあ給料下がりますか
基本的に下がらないです
よっぽどひどい時でも１割とか５％とか
下げてなんとか凌ぎます
なぜって会社に保有があるから
利益上がった時は会社の保有になって
赤字を埋めていくわけです
長期的に赤字を見る
それが日本の会社なんです
日本の老舗企業を見ると
100年企業というのは
ほぼ90何％日本です
海外にはないんです
もう20年来 有名になりましたよね
アメリカの会社とか
スクラップアンドビルドって
言いますよね
分解してパーツにして
売っちゃうんです
そしてまた始める
なぜかというと会社員を
バンバン辞めていって
いい会社があったら
どんどん転職していくんです
だから20代30代はいいですよ
さっさといい会社に就職すればいい
転職すればいい
でも50代60代になって
歳取ってきてローンもあります
どうしましょう
で 転職しないと
会社スクラップアンドビルド
巨大会社だってスクラップアンドビルド
どっちがいいですかね
僕よくわからないんですよね
なぜかって言ったら 利益を
その場で分けちゃうからなんです
もちろん
社会関係するんですね
昔でいうと 漁業だと
儲かったときに使っちゃう傾向があります
お金というのは   次の航海で
生きて帰ってくるかわかんないから
だから戦争地域の出身者とか
戦争地域にいるような人たちは
下の傾向
海外のような傾向がある
でも安定したような
日本社会みたいなところは
長期傾向になるんです
だから日本社会はもの凄く強いんです
今は困っていますけどね
つまり　生物 人間も生物なんです
生物は
種を超えて
例えばヒカゲノカズラとか
地衣類の仲間は
藻類と菌類と全く別のもの同士が協力して
樹の上にぶら下がってみたり
北極とか南極の石の上とか
氷の上とかでも生きてます
だから極限環境でも生きるように
協力しているんです
生物の社会でも分業したり
いろんなことをやって協力関係を作る
人間社会も一部そうしてます
生き残りを模索しているんですね
絶滅を避けて長く生きましょうという
強いものは
だから他者を引きのけて
長期的には没落してちゃうんです
では 人間社会でも共存協力すれば
長期安定する
僕らは考えてほしいのは
ひとり勝ちじゃないんです
自分が一番良い学校行って一番を
とってどうのこうのじゃなくて
協力することを学ぶことが
大事じゃないかなと思っています
どうも
これでおしまいにしたいと思います
（拍手）